Hello,
and welcome to this episode of Rawkode live.
I am your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're doing something a little different. We're
gonna do some live debugging of production
ish Kubernetes clusters that have been broken
by some Kubernetes community members.
Now I'm not gonna do this alone. I
am joined by Waleed Shari, a very active
Kubernetes community member regarding all around awesome dude.
Hey, how is it going?
Thank you. Hi David, how are you? I'm
very well, thank you. I'm very excited for
today's, I'm gonna call it a mission. I
think this is gonna be a very interesting
episode and I hope we can you know
through the process of what we're gonna do
today,
share some of our knowledge and the way
that we work with everybody and everyone will
be a little bit more familiar with Kubernetes.
I'm hopeful I'm hoping to do so also.
Mean, it's I don't know what what I
have put myself into, but yes.
Yeah, I mean, I've definitely got some concerns.
Let's
set the scene right, we've got two Kubernetes
clusters.
They're both deployed with the cluster API project
on Equinix metal. They're highly available control planes
with the worker nodes each. I've thrown on
some sample workloads onto them, a WordPress blog
and MySQL database
and I'm just was
silly enough to say hey who wants to
keep configs for this and this happened to
break them for them and we had two
people
offer, well we had more than two people,
but we're gonna do two today, so the
first two clusters were broken courtesy of Dan
Fennerin, who is also a colleague of mine
at Ecnic Metal and Lee Briggs, a developer
and developer advocate for Pulumi.
Now
I don't really know anything,
which is I think what has us both
slightly worried. We don't know
if the API server is gonna respond, we
don't know if the mess with the workloads,
we don't know if the mess we've had,
we don't know anything. Let's just We don't
know anything about these customers.
So
I guess what we need to do is
just get our screen shared
and then run some basic health checks and
and see
what happens.
Yes. So we need to, like, day one
on the job, discover what the clusters are,
what's working, what's not working,
get to know the clusters,
and see if there is any
apparent errors. Just assess the situation first.
And then I'm going to use my
favorite
strategy from a bridge documentary,
a bridge IT documentary.
It's called the IT Crowd.
So
they have a principle. Their first principle is
turn it off and turn it on again.
Did you turn it off? So
that's the principle that I usually do in
troubleshooting.
Well, we'll certainly give it a shot.
And just to I don't know if it
makes matters worse or better, but we have
a comment from Dan, who's watching along with
us today. So,
yeah, if we need Yes, please. If we
need tests, we will definitely
I'm not watching the YouTube, but yes.
Okay, so let's see.
I have my screen shared and ready.
We've got the Kubernetes documentation.
Walid and I certainly do not know everything
nor do we remember everything we learned at
one point in time, so we will be
leveraging the documentation
where we need.
We also have the IP addresses of all
the nodes, we do have SSH access and
hopefully we have control
access, but we will see that in a
moment.
For anyone not familiar, Waleed has an amazing
set of resources on his GitHub profile so
that is Waleed Shari.
The username,
really helpful for anyone looking to take their
CKA, CTD or CKS
exams. Exams and
I
have an SCD cheat sheet because I can
never remember how to work at SCD.
So
step one,
we have kube config for cluster one here.
This one is the cluster broken by Lee.
So first things first, should we run a
get notes? Is that Yes please. But can
you run cluster info first? Let's see the
API. Okay, anything. Yeah, let's see if the
API is responding.
Yeah, that's good at least.
That is good.
That's good. The network is working. Okay, we
can tell that
the CNI is working because all the nodes
are ready.
And we can tell the API is responding
because it responded to our Q control command.
So we can assume the controller is okay.
Can we do get bots minus capital A
to see?
Oh, we have I've ran out get component
statuses and we can see the scheduler and
the control manager. The scheduler. Okay.
Control manager. Okay. But I'm really happy that
HCD is happy.
Okay.
So what we can do, we can check
the manifest for the scheduler and the controller
manager on the master node.
In that case, we have three master nodes.
Do you want to see the outputs of
get pods all namespaces first? Most
likely we'll see bending. Do we see bending?
Can we grip for bending?
Yeah. Sure.
Strange. I mean, the scheduler is so basically
these were run.
So nothing Okay. Can you schedule
Can you run an
NGINX image?
Can you run a cube control run bot?
Run NGINX image NGINX. Yeah.
Dash dash. Okay,
let's see.
Container, oh.
So basically
maybe one, okay, maybe not all the schedulers
are down
because we just need one scheduler to be
up.
Well,
I would expect the image to pull it
a little faster than that. Let's give it
a few more seconds and see if we
actually get a running container, but it does.
If you do, can you do cube control
describe on the NGINX because we will see
that it was scheduled.
So successfully assigned, you see.
So it was assigned to the node. That
means that the scheduler was working.
So
maybe not all the schedulers are down.
We can go one I mean
so
it's helpful if you have a better SH
command like BDSH or Ansible or whatever.
But let's go the traditional way, one node
at a time.
Okay, so let's say talk about what's your
hypothesis? Do you have anything right now or
are we still just kinda looking around? What
are you thinking here? Okay. Let's do
if you do cube control minus
and the namespace cube system
and get bots, yes.
And
let's grab for a schedule.
So I see
Yeah. We have three schedulers here. Do you
wanna get the logs?
So they are running, correct? It looks like
it, yeah.
Let
me check. So everything is running.
Scheduler cluster, yeah. Let's check it along with
one of Okay,
good. Successfully required leads, yeah.
There was a leader election done.
Okay.
Interesting.
K. Interesting.
Yes. Can you do again the
cube control cluster info?
So
control is running. Kubectl is fine.
Okay. Now do the component again. Get component
status.
So get.
It's doing get.
So the unhealthy
connect, connect refuse.
So if you look at the address,
yeah? Mhmm.
It's a local
loopback address. Yeah, so this is the probes
on the scheduler, should we take a look
at Yes.
So if we just do
get pods,
describe pods, pop open a scheduler.
I can't scroll in t mux. Let's use
a pager.
Yes. Yes.
Okay, I want to check if there is
a reason or anything. State started, yeah, ready
through, that's fine. This one it looks The
ports are different.
The
ports on this is one zero two five
nine, one zero two five nine whereas our
error message was
one zero Let me run that get CS
again.
1 0 2 5 1. I wonder if
the
probes
are changed on one of the schedulers.
Maybe we should check them Let's be
open minded
and let's check the API server.
What's the configuration for the controller manager at
what board it's listening to?
Sorry, can you say that again?
So
our source of truth for board's numbers would
be the
ABI,
the cube ABI.
Correct?
So if
we check the manifest for the cube ABI
to see
what ports configured for
the controller manager.
Okay.
What do you think? Yeah. Let's
let's so you want to describe
I want I want to one of nodes.
Right? Oh, I want to go to one
of the master nodes. Yes. Alright. Alright. Let's
grab this IP address then. So
we can do a SSH.
And these should be deployed through a static
manifest. Is that right?
Yes. Correct.
So let's minus L. Yeah,
can we or
yeah, the Kube API server?
Okay,
you would need You want the API server?
No, no, it's okay. In fact,
this is the future, right? You could type
in my machine.
Yes.
There you go. I'll just I'll just chill
back a little bit. You've got this.
Okay. I don't see anything related to the
controller.
Secure port.
Okay. Actually, it's the other way around.
So it is 10257.
This is the liveness probe.
Okay.
So I've I've got a question. Right? Like,
we we run and get pods on the
cube system namespace
and what we see is three
schedulers appear to be healthy. One controller manager
that appears to be healthy.
However,
component status is the same as unhealthy.
Now how are we getting this disconnect here?
Do we know what could cause that?
It could be the health checks are the
wrong ones.
Yeah. So basically it is listening on a
different port, but the health checks are doing
a different port.
One zero two.
Sorry. Two.
So
okay.
So now I saw a roll of course
there.
Oh, okay. Sorry. No. No. It's all had.
Cube control.
Minus n cube system.
You'll need to yeah. We're not gonna have
access to that on the noise. You'll need
to use the admin cube config. The admin.com
is a cube config. Yeah. I've just dropped
into my machine. Okay.
Grab that.
Okay. And the current controller
and we need the cube system namespace.
Yeah. It's already there. It's at the start.
You're good.
Oh, okay.
Okay. Let's describe one of them.
Yeah.
Okay. Excess, you're all good.
K. It just auto expands.
Oh, okay. Good.
And I'll copy and paste that controller manager
for you if you want.
I'm not used to this.
Yeah. I'll I'll here. I I could do
it. Right? We wanna do a describe. Describe.
Yes.
And not
the cube color scheduler. No. Cube control.
No manager. Okay.
And what was it?
Control name
and then m g, let's say.
Okay.
We have to do less.
What happened?
Hold on. Let me fix it. There you
go. Are we typing together? Okay. Let's see.
Can we see the boards?
Can you go less?
Okay.
So
You see port and host port, there is
none.
I don't this is normal.
Let me
do you want to go to the other
cluster and use it as a check?
Okay.
To see what's the baseline. I don't think
this is normal to have the board as
none.
Which container is this? Yeah, this is the
controller manager. It should be listening on 10
to 50, is it?
Okay, why is it saying none?
Okay.
Okay. So let let's
I think I understand what you're suggesting here.
So let's make sure we make this clear
for the people that are So we are
missing maybe configuration,
yes. I'm thinking, are we missing a configuration?
Yes, so and when we do a get
pods and everything looks healthy, this is because
the liveness probes on the controller manager and
the scheduler are using local IP addresses 127001
and a port which will work, right? However,
get component statuses was reporting that our controller
manager and our scheduler are unhealthy. Now the
component statuses checks aren't gonna use the 127001
address, they're gonna use the cluster address for
it.
What Wally does notice is that when we
take a look at the
description of this is that there is no
port or host port defined on this Which
means that that cluster address would not work
and components would think that things are unwell.
So
I think that's a good lead. But the
controller manager, okay, because we did the bot,
maybe we should try a replica set
or
a deployment. But before we're doing this, let's
try with the traditional tools. Let's do netstat
minus three year LBN
and check. You'll want to be on the
machine, right? We are not anymore, yeah. Yeah,
we can just do it. Racing
conditions we had. There you go.
Let's say not stat
minus t u l b n to listen
to TCB, UDB,
and port numbers as numbers
and grab
control.
Okay. It's listening on 10 to 57,
which is correct as in the health check.
Yep.
So
I think you're right. Why don't we let's
assume that our second cluster doesn't have this
problem. We wanna be able to correlate what
we think our hypothesis is to confirm it.
So But are we actually
are we
causing us problems?
This looks healthy.
We managed to run a bot.
We didn't manage to run a bot.
Did we? No. I thought they did container
creating.
Okay. So container creating.
Okay. Can we run events again against it?
So basically, the scheduler did work.
And
okay.
Failed create what sandbox. Cubelet combined from similar
failed to create what sandbox.
We have to set up network for RK
for sandbox,
enable to connect to Selium daemon.
Okay. So it looks like
can we do again? So it's here. It's
saying that our CNI is Cilium.
Can we do
How did we miss that?
I don't know.
I didn't miss it.
Because we did a cat A.
Yes. So can we look at the daemon
set that is responsible for that?
Can can
Yes. I just even set minus a. Cilium
namespace.
Is it Cilium or CubeSystem? Oh yeah, it
is Cilium. Okay.
So none none of them is ready.
Okay.
Okay. None of them is ready.
No. I think we're going have to get
the logs of one of these ciliums to
see if we can see any other messages.
Yes. Let's describe first. Usually when there is
a crash loop back off, I do the
logs because it's usually the application.
But to describe, there is a reason
and sometimes this reason is quite good enough.
Can you repeat again with less or grab
for capital reason? Capital R, easy.
Yes.
So just saying crash to back off.
Okay. Let's do the logs then. Let's do
the logs with the previous log so to
see what the error was.
Minus
minus p
for previous.
Yeah.
Detected, mounted, valid table,
prefix.
Rawkode requires IP tables.
Is the so Selium can use
Selium uses BBF. Correct?
It can do. Yes.
So is the config for Selium
cluster?
Okay.
This is
Let's see. You're going fast.
So I'm just looking for anything, looks like
an error message.
Okay. So that is the first error message.
So we got a What is it? We
have a warp number of and
then we have a l seven proxy requires
IP table rules, install IP table rules.
We just messing one parameter?
Proxy requires IP table rules. So it's telling
us it requires a certain IB table rules.
Okay.
Let's use the bridge documentary for this one.
Let's do the IB tables
minus capital l. But the problem with IB
tables,
we'll see lots of stuff. Let's let's try.
What is the problem here? I I don't
know if it's IB tables on the host
or selling them is telling us that it
doesn't have access to the
conflict stuff and now it's trying to get
that Is it using but it doesn't have
the flag on the template,
right? Is that what it's saying? Yes. So
if we do an edit DS Celeb,
unless you jump down to all these parameters
that we pass into the pod.
Man, that's too fast.
Yeah, sorry. Just get to the bit we
need to do.
Where's args?
It was most likely it is in a
config map.
Of course.
Or secret.
But most likely it's a config map.
Okay. In in cvm space, can you do
get all?
Yeah.
Haven't created cvm before. Okay. I think
yes. Okay. Let's see what we have. Always
use our.
So let's try that Centimeters again. Yeah. There
we go.
It helps if you spell it right.
Oh, you need minus n? You did minus
n, correct? Oh, but I didn't. No, but
but yes. Centimeters,
sorry. Yes, I think we could just add
notes here.
It's not ib table rules.
Oh, wait. What happens
if I don't want to use ib, because
it says enable ib version four on top.
But what happens if I want to use
e b b f, install ib table rule
false? Yeah. Try this one also.
Why is it both? Ah, so it's a
duplicate. I think there's a typo, and then
there's a false But which one is correct?
Because you have rule and rules. Now time
to hit the manuals. Time to hit the
main pages or the documents. Well, the logs
told us, so
we go to the bottom of this log,
rules, plural.
So
Okay. Let's restart our let's put our selling
pods and see if they get happy.
Yeah. I'm glad that you are here.
I'm glad that you're here.
We'll
deal with this together. So I've just restart
What did that? Sorry to interrupt. But that's
a realistic
that's one of the realistic problems in Linux
and Unix and the Kubernetes in general is
typos. Most of the problems is us
doing the type on a configuration map or
somewhere.
Yeah. The difficulty here is,
I don't know if Lee has broken or
BPF configuration and fixing it by enabling IP
tables is still a valid
way to fix it, but we may not
be fixing
the real issue, but if our customers happy
that's a win on our books, Selvium namespace,
so.
I must specify the resource cookie. Yeah. Sorry.
I I would type. No. Go ahead. Go
ahead.
K and Celeum
get pods.
Okay.
Let's do a get c s and see
if that fixes.
Healthy.
If you do the the thing is when
we did k get nodes, everything was ready.
So there was communication between the nodes. That
pod they're scheduled,
so maybe a component status is just a
little behind, we're gonna have to wait for
the
check to catch up,
but we may have fixed this.
We got out, we were able to schedule
our pod. Let's see if our application is
still running. We maybe should have done that
from the start, but So
port forward,
s v c, WordPress,
80.
So the fastest way to check,
I mean, that your cluster is working is
basically you run a workload.
And running a bot is the simplest workload
to have. I would say deployment
will exercise
the replica set controller.
So let's
create a deployment.
We we have one here.
Let's work with this as
our sample workload, which is is running just
fine. We never changed the area. But the
thing, if it was running before,
nothing would happen.
Okay.
Unless you delete the bots, okay, if you
want to try. So you don't need to
create a new deployment.
Just delete the bots for the WordPress.
Okay. Alright. Let me close that. So get
pods.
So the controller manager is several controllers.
One of them is for nodes, nodes controller.
One is for the replica set
among other
daemons and stuff like this.
And they are registered.
So I don't think we have a problem
with the controller manager anymore.
I am so worried about this get component.
But the bot was, it was not 10252,
was it?
The bot was,
I think I thought the bot had seven
when we did netstat.
Yeah, this might be a red herring.
Let's just say that this was deprecated in
01/19, this cluster is one nineteen,
but maybe this just doesn't work.
Maybe just doesn't report healthy here. We could
check, let's why don't we
I'm happy that our workload is running, we
fixed the Selium problem, Selium started working,
I don't think we have any pods that
are not running.
Yes. So let's do okay. Let's move on
to cluster two and then we'll see if
the get component status is fails there. And
if it does, we'll consider that just a
one nineteen thing.
And let's see if we can tackle the
next problem. And then if we need to,
we'll come back and take a look at
the other problem on this. Can you do
just for my
peace of mind, can you do cube control
get events and let's and grab for
okay. Let's see. Just
get events. It's
like
okay.
And grip minus v normal.
V only. Oh, sorry. I just added that.
It's case insensitive.
Error.
Volume.
Volume is already used. Okay. So
fifth setup network sandbox. This was four minutes.
Work sandbox.
I think So problem.
It's it's fine. But it's running, isn't it?
Yeah. Mhmm.
Okay.
So I mean,
if I do get nodes and if I
do get bots minus a, and if I
do cluster info
We have a working cluster as far I
can And if you run and if you
run, like, a deployment and you expose the
service, let's expose the server.
There's no NGOs configured on this cluster?
Just as a service, as a cluster IP.
Expose NGINX.
Oh, I can't remember the full thing.
The server does not have resource. Expose
SVC
slash NGINX.
But I have to tell it what to
No, no, actually, we
don't have the service yet. Yes.
By
default, I think it's cluster ID. It's
clever enough to figure out the board, isn't
it?
Okay. Good. Get service.
Can you do
get endpoints for this service?
Get EB endpoints.
I just described as service. Okay. That's better
even. Yeah. Yeah. And we have endpoints. So
networking
seems to be fine, at least at the
antenna cluster level.
And creating a bot and the scheduler is
running, the API is running.
I think who
broke this cluster?
Lee Briggs, who is in Seattle, so will
not be available just now to confirm anything
for us. However, he will send a pull
request to the cluster repository to tell us
what he broke. So hopefully we'll fix Okay.
If not,
I think we did pretty well there. So
let's move Do
you want the good news or the bad
news?
So Dan's left us a comment.
We're
having fun, there is no bad news. I
fear I've opted for a less nuanced approach
and gone full sledgehammer on the cluster.
Well, I always knew you were the wild
card then, so that's alright. So Daniel is
the one who broke this cluster? He is.
Broke Okay, thank you Daniel.
I appreciate.
So let's I just want you to be
realistic,
so that we can
so maybe we can actually learn something out
of it. Okay, let's try.
Time man, time Can
you use minus V?
But it looks like okay. Can you do
kubectl config?
I want to view.
Okay. Can we
curl curl the address?
Yeah.
slash A B I or
Yeah. Minus LB. I love minus LB.
So basically,
it looks like we don't have an ABI
server.
Alright. Let's get on this note then.
Okay.
Clustered to
I have a lot of projects here.
Cluster oh, right.
Only issues I had with API servers in
production was from the load balancer.
That the the load balancer was set one
time as the
layer seven load balancer, not a network load
balancer.
And
another time,
basically,
during the installation, this was OpenShift.
So OpenShift starts as a cluster ABI. You
have a node that is a management node,
and And they forgot to include this management
node
as part of the
back ends.
We have no SSH. We
don't have SSH? No, we're going to have
to go in the back door.
Fortunately, could expand But yeah. Has an outbound
console, so that's gonna take us over the
private link.
On a non standard on a standard board,
he said, okay.
I
guess we could port scan it or I
could just go in the back door.
Does he mean non standard or he means
standard board?
This machine's also been up for more than
twenty four hours, so I don't have
root password to actually log in here.
So we've got two options.
How do I quit?
Turn it off.
Thought control square bracket was my
get out of here. Yes, yes, in general,
yes.
Let's just open up. Control square bracket dot,
control square bracket dot usually.
Yeah.
How do I open a new tab on
TMux?
Control B C.
Alright, okay, let's just use this.
Should we port scan this machine and see
if we get anything? Okay, go ahead. And
Matt,
do you think, let's just the
normal range.
Or do you think he's creative?
I have no idea.
No idea what he's done.
It's blocking ICN. You
can try nmap minus s u, s capital
u.
So we do it here. You are requested
to scan, which requires ah, you need sudo
for that. Also the first one probably.
I don't like it today, Dan.
So this is scanning UDP.
There is another one,
SSP, b I think
that basically
doesn't send the
the first the
first sync packet. It starts with sending the
second. I've got an idea. He
he may have done this in all of
the control plane nodes, I bet he hasn't
done it on the worker nodes. I don't
know if he's that evil, so why don't
we just try sneaking in through.
You have a trust between them?
No I'll have to forward my SSH if
I can remember how to do that but
I wanna see if I can even get
on one of these nodes.
No, he has done it on all of
them. Of course he did.
Okay.
Nonstandard.
Okay. He's saying nonstandard.
Let me just a second.
I mean, I would pick 600666.
I
would pick 20202121.
But we can
scan scan using
Okay.
I'm gonna take one of the non important
nodes,
reboot them into a rescue operating system.
So that we get on it and poke
around the disk.
Okay with Just a second. Let's
try.
Anyway, this I'll just this is just a
worker node. So I'm gonna let that do
that. Oh, you are in the worker node?
Are you in the worker node? No, no,
no. I'm rebooting a worker node into a
rescue of a ram based operating system, so
we can get on and poke around. So
while that does that, we can try a
few other things this way.
So do you wanna try that
end map again?
He says we are so close with those
port numbers.
Ah, 20.
Not not as you. SS. To to
I don't know if he's been nice to
us here.
20 one, 20 one usually.
Or 20 two, 20 two. Yeah. What happened
to 22?
There is an n map scanner.
Let's see if this is in its rescue
or less yet.
No. It'll take a couple of minutes.
Okay. So he has just sophisticated the port
20202222.
Doesn't seem to work, but he seems to
suggest You mentioned the
try triple six.
I might have used the wrong IP.
Alright.
We're on a node.
Okay. Which node is that? Control
Control
So what is it? 2222,
correct? Yes.
Okay.
Can we do,
what is it, Docker or Cryo, or what
kind of Container D. Can you do container
d? Okay. Can you do cryo control bots?
Can we do
we do system control and see that container
is running?
System d status
container d. You did the whole stuff.
Container d. Yeah.
Okay. Active, running,
which is good.
And
okay. Can we see the cubelet?
No. Can we check the again, with the
sys with
yeah.
Failed.
Loaded.
Okay. Enabled.
And
activating auto restart. So basically, it's trying to
restart and it cannot restart. Certificates.
Of course it is. Oh, man. I told
you there would be certificates.
Okay. Can we check the
configuration directory, varlib? What does it say? Certificate?
Yep. We're here.
Certificate.
Kubelet client currently loading.
Okay.
I see it looks like the search were
okay.
Right? I do actually see an error message
in the journal v log there.
Can you highlight it?
Can you highlight the error message that you
saw? No, there isn't one. I I see
the search and got worried.
Run journal control minus x. Run journal control
minus u cubelet.
Do you wanna type? Sorry, messed up. Yes.
Oh yeah, that's
You'll need to add a note pager.
Fun.
We reached there.
It was up for twenty four hours. Okay.
Keyblade service failed with exit code.
Oh, I need
What was the exit no major. Did we?
Code dot main process.
I wanna see if our API server is
okay.
It will not be okay because the cubelet
is the one that starts it.
Basically, if you the cubelet No,
it's not running. It's restarting. If you look
at the
you look at system control status.
So basically, there is an error in the
configuration file, most likely.
If you look at the activating auto restart,
this is your key.
It means, in six seconds,
It keeps restarting
it, but it hits the same problem.
And this is one good thing about systemd,
that it
will go forever. It will until
the problem is fixed, hopefully. There you go.
This is the everybody.
The one good thing of
It's the IT crowd principle in
action.
Restart it. Restart it until it's over.
So we take a look at the Kubelet
static manifest? Yeah. Yeah. And not not it's
in the var lib.
Yeah. You see it? A var lib kubelet.
No. A var lib kubelet.
LS
config dot yaml.
Okay. Now,
cluster DNS, cluster local.
One thing we can do,
we can grab the
config from the other one and try here.
Did we actually see an error message here?
There is an error message, but I'm not
sure.
Let's see if we can.
I couldn't find the code. What code was
it?
It says failed.
Okay, another way we can look at the
Wow. That's a lot of
Yes.
There's a log file also. I mean, other
than join and control where
we can do grab against
has
been duplicated. Ah, here. We need to remove
this flag.
I don't think that would stop the cubelet
starting, would it?
Let's see.
What does it say?
The parameter should be set by the config
config flag. Let's see these flags. Are there
or not?
He says it's right in front of us.
So we're looking right at it. Show the
result. Exit code. Main process.
Yeah. It's always right in front of us.
It's mains.
Main process exited here. Okay. So let's
let's see if that flag is here.
Eviction. Eviction. Eviction.
Okay. Can you comment this out?
Or make a copy of the file? That's
not the same one though, right?
Grip.
Effection.
Yeah. That's not the same one.
Effection hard has been deprecated.
This okay. Maybe okay.
Let's find where is the cubelet grip
grip config dot yaml on this one.
What does this message mean? CPU
Can you do
where? Sorry. We've got a c groups per
cause enabled, but secret group is not specified
using slash.
Can you highlight it?
Yeah. And we've got the swap header too.
Swap error.
If this is a cube admin cluster?
Yeah. We should just turn swap off. Right?
Yes. If it's cube admin, it should be
off.
What do we have as well? Minus
a, I guess.
Let's see if that restarts our kubelet.
But I want to see the system control.
I just want to see if the configuration
file is in a different place than normal.
So you see here.
The kubel is running. Oh,
okay. So just swap.
That's really silly, no? We complicated it.
I think we we were good down a
rabbit hole there. Okay. So let's So the
second principle is keep it simple, I think.
And don't jump to conclusions right away.
Alright. Let's see if we got an API
server at least.
So what does he say? Ah, okay.
Please disable swap. Who's that? Oh, I mean.
Alright. So we're I mean, our API server
is still broken, so bring them back on
the node. No. No. Can you go and
check if the bots start running now?
Check if what's running?
Can we see on the the master node,
can we see the
cubelet has started the bots?
Okay. Can we do docker b s? There
is no docker, so basically, try control b
s.
Oh, there is no okay. Can we restart
the container container d?
System.
Good. Good. Good.
Can we check the status of the container
d? It should show that.
Looks alright. Okay. Yep.
Okay.
So it was a container.
API server's
been running.
Can you try try
control b s?
So basically, Cry Control BS will show us
the container images.
I mean, the bot is running.
Process
so
can you do cube control status,
the container d? Let's see again.
Yeah. Status, container d. Good.
Okay. So
active running
and basically
looks good. Can we do Jordan control minus
u?
Jordan control minus u and container d.
No major, and maybe follow minus f also.
So
you want to try from the other tab
on TMax to check the cube controller? It
should work now.
It doesn't.
But It doesn't? He did joke about IP
table rules at the start.
Yeah.
Yeah. The problem with IP rules is that
there are too much. Queue firewall
anywhere anywhere.
So we got
Yeah. We've got this.
Which one?
Nothing. Nothing yet. Start looking.
That's
oh.
You did
the main
part is
startup.
I hate IP tables. Let's
Okay. Let's
Okay.
Is it I b system control?
And let's check if firewall d is on.
What what what kind of system is it?
Status? It went to USWR.
Okay.
And we've all the rules We
could see the allow rule for Port 2222.
Let's just
go through the last. Let's see.
Okay.
Let's try to find the Should we just
add a rule to just to load that?
No. I
want to check
6443.
Can I do a slash 6443?
Okay. I shouldn't actually. I don't think we'll
have a rule to allow that. I'm assuming
we've got some very
heavy handed dropping going on here. So why
don't we just add a rule to allow
that port and then see.
But why okay. Can we do
can we do a trace against a trace?
Where did our API server go?
That was running a minute ago.
So
somebody is asking, Daniel, he's saying disable UFW.
Is UFW like on top of IB tables?
I'm not sure about that.
Yes. We're looking at the rules for it
right now and I could disable it, but
I thought that would be a bit heavy
handed too. Figured we could just allow the
port, but sure.
Why not?
Since we are, I mean, I guess we
don't need to fix this gracefully. We can
we just need to fix it.
I still don't see an API server at
our PS output, which was there a few
Can you check the status of the cubelet
maybe?
Yeah.
Yeah. It's happy.
It is happy.
Cry control bots still bad.
Yeah. Something wrong with that. Cry control b
s.
Can we do a strace against it?
See where it's stuck.
Oh, you don't have strace.
We can fix that. Something I know how
to do. There we go.
Okay.
So it's trying to do View text open.
Such file directory.
Use that.
Failed to connect.
Failed to connect. So still, we have
some network issue.
Contact the okay.
You mentioned etcd. Correct?
Yeah. The container would use etcd. Right?
Why not?
Because it doesn't use etcd. I mean, if
we were the Kubernetes class for container data.
Yeah.
Yeah. But here,
the this error message is usually you see
it on
field connect context deadline exceeded.
I see it on HCD when the certificates
are wrong,
but I might be wrong in this case.
Okay. Let's take a look at Kubernetes. So
the system fail is in
lib
system b system
then container d.
That's useless. Okay.
I would look at the logs first.
Okay.
Returns
looks like the containers d is doing its
job. It's creating containers.
Yep.
Do you have Docker client here?
No. If we can install it though.
No. No. You don't need to install. I
mean, try control should be doing the job
for
It's not a WW.
Okay.
So
we know that cry control cannot talk and
usually talks to socket.
Unless
so
This is a hard one, Dan. Thanks a
lot. I said this is a hard one,
Dan. Thanks a lot.
It's bugging me that
when I grant for API server previously,
it was showing.
No, it's not that I'm not getting past
that,
hold on. Let's try let's restart our kubelet
system.
Something's not right here. I mean, many things
are probably not right here, but something specifically
here is not right.
Okay.
Why are these manifests not started? Do we
have etcd?
Right. Okay. We do.
Do we have
controller?
We don't have a controller And
so we have a schedule. So there's something
wrong with API server and controller manager manifests
here.
Okay.
And so
basically,
it is the Kubernetes manifest.
Okay,
let's,
so any of these started?
He suggested we look at the kubelet again.
So
the kubelet has a configuration where it looks
where the manifests are.
And it's under
under Etsy.
If you go see the
me go. Yeah. Go for it.
Etsy system,
the system
kubelet,
less,
and this one.
Okay. Now here
so
environment, kubelet, kubelet axe, bootstrap, it's Kubernetes bootstrap,
kubelet.com,
kubelet config Yaml.
Is it not configured to have static manifests?
Should we get the docs up on this
one?
Yes.
Let me check another cluster.
It has a pod manifest fast. It's not
not being passed
via kubla args. You can check the other
cluster, by the way.
Let's just add it to this.
Kubernetes
manifest.
No. It's not manifest.
It's Kubernetes manifest.
The environment file basically.
No. Am I wrong?
What did you do? I didn't see.
So
in this file,
I added a flag to our kubelet to
see pod manifest path is slash etcetera slash
Kubernetes slash manifests.
And it's
Make sure the kubelet's actually got that.
Okay.
That's a pain in it. It has to
read that.
No. You have Kube API server up.
Oh, I do know. As of ten seconds
ago. Okay. Cool.
No. Can you
but it died. Okay. We can look at
the logs, by the way.
So the logs
let's let's do this a second. Can you
give me control? Yeah. Take it.
Okay. Cat Cubelet.
You
Cube API server.
So there's API server struggling to speak.
Oh, the 10.
It's 18. Emissions controller.
Yeah. Can't reach NCT.
Endpoint.
Var scheme endpoint.
CBC resolve rubber.
2379.
Yeah. This looks like an HCD thing.
Yeah. The context exceeded.
Important is wrong. That's why 2379
versus 2381.
So Okay. Let's
We can fix that, right, by going to
The manifest again. Yes. Yeah.
Okay. Find
endpoint.
Yeah. That's it.
No. You didn't fix it. Did you fix
it? Yeah.
You are very quick, man. No. It's still
2381.
It should be It was 2379,
and then I changed it to 2381 because
when I did a I grabbed on etcd,
the port was 2381.
It's here.
Oh,
no. But when you did the grip on
HCD
just a second.
This is
somebody is running. Where is it? Yeah. So
is on port 2381.
Part of which process?
No? Oh, yeah. Okay.
Dennis.
So maybe you should fix it from here.
Well, which which is the valid the real
NTD port?
It is to here. Initial cluster,
and 2380.
Here it's 2379.
You just went on a port random thing
and started messing up ports.
So this is for the beers initial cluster.
23792379238
here. This one. This is metrics. This metrics.
Listen beer, 2380.
Lifeless probe.
Okay. So let me fix the API server
again. Sorry.
Because I I said okay. So you're saying
I've changed that the wrong way around, which
makes sense.
So
What was it before you changed it? To
three seven nine. So let's put it back
to that.
Did you make a change in the NADC
one?
Did you change anything here?
No. I didn't.
Alright.
Let's check this kubelet thing again.
So q config.
Q config.
What manifest? It is easy to manipulate the
manifest. Correct?
Config. Well, the config.
Runtime.
Run container d, container sock,
eviction, hard memory.
Yeah. That's alright.
Our API server. Check this one. It has
to be the API server.
It has to be the API server.
Can we check the socket?
Yeah. It is there. So why control b
s is not working?
Hold on.
Can you look at the minute two gig
of memory available, we're gonna start infecting stuff.
Oh, yeah.
That doesn't seem right.
Can we check the
try Check the kubelet Where was that kubelet
thing again? Do you wanna jump back into
that? I can't remember where that was. The
kubelet. Okay.
It's under it's in your system.
System
cube. Let
and
there is two, by the way. There is
the unit, which is in a different place.
Yeah. And this is the override for the
unit.
So do we have to have no. There's
no eviction here, is there? No. So maybe
we need to go to the
so see that in this flags fail or
it might be in the unit fail.
The general control would show us that. Okay.
Can you go again? The beam can
description, documentation on software. You're really fast, man.
I'm sorry. Know I really
so it's not in the unit file. It
wasn't in the QBDM flag. It wasn't in
the config that you found.
So
where else is it going to Bootstrap config.
It's the
can we check the Bootstrap the this one?
This file? Yeah.
No.
There is no file bootstrap.
So
do we need this file? So he's passing
a pack
he's passing a flag to the kubelet.
But do we need this file to bootstrap?
No. I don't think we do.
I think
Where was the
can you go back to that other
QPDM config you had, please?
This one? No. Which one?
We are in
the current directory.
I could have just done cd dash probably
that would have worked. Do cd dash.
Where are we? Yes.
Strange.
Why I don't see it.
Yeah. Hold on. Can I type?
Yeah.
Okay. Yes. Yeah. This
default
should put it.
Vixen. That's it. You you found it.
Remove the call. Comment the call.
Sorry. I'm just reading that and laughing.
Alright. Let's do daemon
reload.
Restart.
No,
that's so the API server was running, it
was disappearing. I'm glad I didn't make that
up when I was doing that PS. So
now we wanna test the API server again.
Okay.
Back on the note.
No. He didn't. We we definitely have an
API server now. So I'm gonna test it
with the admin conf.
Okay.
So
let's confirm that this is the API servers
running on 6443.
How many many problems did you put in
this thing then? Really?
443.
4 0. Correct.
And we've got is that IP And you
can check using let's let's say also.
Yeah. Go for it.
Oops.
The b n server is not It's not
Is it down again? Well
Did you did you restart it?
Yeah. Was running. Yeah. Search for API.
Okay. API server.
Okay. The ties address.
Is this the correct address?
Let's
check. There's not really anything out.
75180.
And we've got an elastic IP on the
bond of 8045.
What was the netstat output?
Sorry, the PS output. Yeah.
Oh, it's down again. It's
gone.
Let's check the locks.
Log
containers.
Kubernetes.
Maybe I
k. We need the last log.
So
we need the last log.
You want me to copy and paste all
that?
Oh, happened?
The the the other section.
Okay. It's just too weird. I'm still my
That's q. Yeah. Cluster002.
Tap tap.
Okay. V18.
2 log. Yeah? Yeah? 32.
Oh, 33. Let's do 33.
Context deadline exceeded again.
Keyword.
Edit. Loaded.
Plug in.
Loaded. Bar schema. Endpoint.
CC server.
Can we check 2379?
Yeah. Endpoint.
Contacts
So I was trying to speak to entity
on our local
Yes. The thing is I
my problem is
Yeah. We're talking My problem I need I
I I want to know why this is
not working.
I want to know why CryControl is not
working. Should I
So we have two big problems right now.
One, the API server keeps rebooting because it
can't speak to etcd and
we have no way to enter out with
the container d process. Yes.
So if CryControl is working,
I will actually use etcdControl
from the etcdControl
to check
etcdHealth
because this looks like
etcd is not responding on time. We could
try and enter and jump into the entity
namespace.
What process number is it?
7553.
What?
Is that rewritten as well?
Oh.
Let's see if we can catch it before
it goes away.
So
we want
let's see if it's still there.
Yeah.
It's a key enterprise client,
2379.
Server cert client
certification
directory.
Let me grab my entity cheat sheet. Where
is it? No. No. It it looks fine.
We I went through the manifest and it
was a server key.
It's in client. I think he said earlier,
entity wasn't
touched. Yeah. The problem is an SCD. So
okay. Can I do
we have SCD controls here, type?
Just want to check.
No. We definitely install it.
Yeah.
That's why I was gonna try and do
it in a center and to its
namespaces so that we could just pretend we're
in it even though we're not.
I want to check why control is not
working.
Because Dan hates us.
Okay. I'm trying to check which file it
opens.
Failed to connect.
It's
Dan's given us a hint, of course.
The entity cluster won't be healthy because of
the firewall probably in all the control plane
nodes, so we'd probably have to disable it
on them all. Oh, yes. Because we did
only in one node. Yes.
Yes. Yes. Yes.
So you have to log in to each
node then.
That's why it's useful to have a valid
SH like PDSH.
Yeah. I wonder if he added
default things to the mall. Of course he
did.
And
this one.
I'm not sure what failure scenario Dan had
in his head here. I'm assuming our conflict
management was so messed up that we rolled
out this change to everything.
Okay.
And
stop. Get f w and just because I
wanna know.
Maybe I need to just
tackle things a little bit here.
Just encourage it
and we'll do that for the previous node
as well.
I'm not sure if it actually reloads the
default params or if they get cached, so
Okay. Alright.
Let's just jump back onto node one and
see if we can see what's happening.
Okay. Where are we? API server.
No.
So SCD might just need a minute, I
guess. Just
a second, system.
I want to check if he played with
other
network stuff.
Minus a.
Grip.
Forward.
Assist
controls.
What?
I p v four dot I p underscore
forward.
That's
no. It's okay.
So I didn't play with that one.
Disable
the firewall and the other nodes. I just
did the control plane nodes.
I don't think I would need to do
the worker nodes. Feel free to correct me.
You don't need to do the con con
worker nodes
because basically what we wanted is the quorum
for HCD.
So HCD is like in every now and
then, they will check who who's the leader.
Also, the scheduler and the
basically, they will do, a leadership election.
Let me just confirm.
Good tap there from a
different Yeah.
I didn't know that.
So
I bet you I need to start it.
You can do ibtables
flush and then restart the cubelet.
So ibtables
minus capital f.
Yep. Already done.
Let's get the other one done.
So
we disable
flush
restart.
And back onto our first control plane node.
Can you do cry control b s? Because
I think this is what was stopping my
cry control from
okay. I'm with minus flash. Good.
You start.
Okay.
Type impressions. I
love the duplicate. Yes.
No.
Do we need to restart also the container
d? No. Here, I'll restart the whole thing
if I need to.
Like you said, just turn it off and
on again. Yeah. I
don't know why is that.
Alright. We have an API server.
I'm gonna try
that didn't reject it.
Alright. Host.
Do we still have an API, sir? No.
K.
Okay. Let's go back one step.
Alright. Well, we have ten
minutes left. So
let's
oh, Dan, I really hate you.
He turned on swap and all the notes,
of course he did. Right.
So you you disabled swap and all the
notes. Correct? No. I I just disabled one
note. I'm a cowboy.
So that means swap off
Smiley isn't it?
Restart kubelet.
Dart mode.
Okay.
Swap off.
That's a good thing for me to remember
for future episodes of this since that people
are thrilled and will break all the nodes
and not just one of them.
I think Dan is cruel.
Okay. Let's jump back onto the first node.
We'll try a couple more things and then
we'll just ask Dan to maybe
we'll just get this working before we wrap
up for today. So
let's
see what happens with
yeah. Let's
try get notes.
No, we're still
broken.
Do we have an API server?
No.
So maybe SCD has just not got a
core yet,
which would mean that the server wouldn't be
able to start. Okay. Okay. Should we be
able to check the server logs to see
for a different error, I guess? The so
the SCD logs are in the same place.
Varlib
Varlib containers, HCD there. So
if I cannot get to the container, at
least I can get its logs.
Okay. The Varlog container. Right?
Yes.
HCD.
No. It would be just the and it
It's a scheduler.
And let's grab the HDD.
Yeah. I don't know why it's not all
complete.
Yeah. So
let's get one of these. Let's, for example,
this one this one.
Did we get the right one?
I hope so.
Oh, sorry. You type.
Okay.
Not such five.
Yeah. I think it's only pasted half of
it.
Well, thanks for that vote of confidence, Dan.
He thinks
we've fixed it.
And the other Daniel, Daniel Louen Lou Ellen
has said that we may have just overwritten
that Rawkode file.
We might have what? Overwritten the
that log.
Maybe.
But there are two of them.
Okay. Why don't we just do cat etcd
star?
Okay.
Let's see if that works. There.
Helpful k?
So etcd is not an issue.
There was indicating a symlink. Yeah. That's
only healthy for thirty seconds. So why don't
we test,
get notes?
Okay. So
we just had to wait for LCD to
be happy.
Settle.
Okay. Can we try our bots?
Okay.
Can we do that? Okay.
That's good. Cluster oh, crash through back up.
The control manager.
Alright.
No Definity.
Don't tell me he did the No Definity
also.
You want to check the RawDefinity or do
you want to check the Control Manager? Control
Manager, I think is the best. Yeah.
Okay.
So we have one Right. Not a problem.
I never used minus f for logs. What
is my oh, minus f follow. Okay. Yeah.
I
would do the for a crash loop, I
would usually do the previous because the previous
will show will terminate in an error
if there is an error.
But, also, I would I would love to
describe first just to check the reason.
And if you grab for reason
Reason crash loop back off. Very helpful indeed.
Okay.
Okay. So what do we got?
I think it might just need to restart
it.
Quote quota monitor.
Quote
monitor.
Restart the resource quota. Ah, there is a
resource quota.
Can you check OC okay. OC. Cube control
get quota. Good.
On the cube system.
There is no no resource. Okay. How about
network policies?
Net one?
Okay. It's not that evil.
Yeah. Hold on. Let's find a real error
here. But it says I saw some quota
messages. Error start to node IPAM.
Failed to mark CIDR 1 9 2 1
6 8 0 0 Slash 20 4 IDX
occupied. 1323.
Dan thinks these are red headings.
He says it's not him.
Okay. They read they read they read the
bots and let's see. Yeah. Oh, it looks
like a call DNS controller manager.
Is one of them running? One of them
is no. But it's not ready. It's running,
but it's not ready. And we have bending.
Why is it bending? Can we check why
it's bending?
Two seconds.
Cube control.
My second.
Describe.
Nope.
Okay.
You're a terrible person, Dan.
Terrible person. Container image. Okay. Already present a
machine. Change the and recreate it.
You control.
Get
rep
controller.
So let's jump
on to the first node. The first node.
Update another location.
Warning. Invalid disk capacity.
This was six minutes.
Can you do queue control describe node this
node?
Cluster.
Yeah.
And allocated resources.
I don't okay. So do you remember can
you go up? Let's do less.
Okay.
Conditions. Network unavailable.
Memory is good. Disc pressure falls. Disc VID
pressure.
Ready. So what's the capacity CPU? 48.
So why did I get this this case
with there?
Okay.
You have a metric server?
Why does it say this capacity is wrong?
Okay. Let's run the a cube control events
and create for warming.
Oh, yeah.
Keep get the events. Yep.
Okay. Why does it say
invalid disk capacity? This was fifteen minutes ago,
fifteen minutes ago,
and it's all in cluster two. Maybe they
forgot cluster two. You didn't remove the eviction
and stuff.
I thought You got it to press
on image file system. On image file system.
Yeah. Or two over
He
said he said the side arrange to local
host.
Testing.
Where did the controller manager go?
Try again.
Oh, if you did you need to restart
the kubelet if you change the network
because you need to restart all bots.
So basically, restarting the kubelet will be actually,
restarting the node will be the easiest.
But restarting the kubelet might
Yeah. We've got a control manager. He said
he
said he did it on the first control
plane.
So the problem with network settings,
all bots will have the wrong settings,
so you have to basically restart them all.
When we ah, basically,
restarting the container runtime will will get you
the same effect.
Actually, restarting the node would be better.
He left again.
Oh, you're funny.
I think our cluster's healthy now. Right?
I'm not going to use it.
I'll stay away from this kind of clusters.
So we fixed
I mean
I bet.
You can help it.
Oh, you have self response. He's probably did
that same change on the other nodes. Right?
Oh, no. I got the cluster CIDR wrong.
Oh, 192. What was it? Well, I thought
our cluster CIDR was 19216800Slash16.
Let's see. But maybe it's actually 17200016.
Because our pod CIDR yeah. Our pod CIDR
would be Yes. Yes. Yes.
How are you doing for time while we
while we wrap this up?
I guess so.
Thanks, Dan. It was fun, at least.
So what do you think? How realistic was
it? So
UFW,
I think it could be realistic. I saw
it I saw some basically, someone is going
to install something on a node. And this
is the problem if you have fat nodes,
Buntu, Red Hat, or something like this, not
like container operating systems
like FlatCar or Fidora CoreOS or something like
this.
So they do an update or they want
to install an extra software to test or
something like this, and they will add another
rule. And they forget that this is, like,
a different node and it's specific, especially in
test cluster. This will never happen in production.
No? I don't think this will happen in
production. Hopefully not, Daniel.
Well, that yeah. That was the only problem
yeah. We had the firewall, we then had
Yeah. The weird eviction rules,
idea how those got there. Yes. We got
the four or 15 terabyte files in the
root partition and the root file system.
There was the
cluster cider tweaks across the controller. The swap
could happen. The swap, I saw this happen.
The swap, yes. For the cube admin cluster,
that that's definitely
is happening.
I mean, for managed cluster for and for
on premise turnkey clusters like OpenShift or Rancher,
I don't need to play with the manifest.
I don't need to play with the configurations
of the API and the scheduler. Scheduler.
The CIDR, I only needed in the beginning
of the installations.
Well, I think we we had some fun.
That was that was really interesting. I think,
you know, even just the the way that
hopefully the way that we work with the
tools, looking at the different components, the logs,
system d, where configuration lives, I hope a
lot of people find this useful and it
helps them debug on Kubernetes clusters in the
future.
Thank you to Lee and to Dan for
their tire fire clusters. Hopefully we fixed Lee's.
I'll speak to him afterwards.
And I'll be back next week with two
more broken clusters.
Thank you, Dan. Dan will not be back.
Sorry, mate. You're you're out.
Well, thank you for taking some time out
of your day joining me today, sharing your
knowledge. It was great just to see your
thought process and how we work with Kubernetes.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. Have great day. Thanks for watching
everyone. Yes, that's fine. Bye. Bye.